qu'est-ce que tu parles de voler ah non
je dis que vous fouillez bien partout
pour voir si je vous ai volé c'est ce
que je veux faire
trop mais que la peste soit de l'avarice
et des apparitions
nous avons décidé de lancer sur les
lignes une semaine de sensibilisation au
bien voyagé ensemble au respect des
règles de civisme et de civilité dans
nos trains et dans nos gares donc on a
voulu aborder cette thématique là sur un
angle un petit peu décalé en surprenant
les nos clients
avec l'intervention d'une troupe de
comédiens qui a le principe c'est
vraiment de jouer dans les trains de je
veux un théâtre populaire un peu dans le
principe de Molière on joue du théâtre
classique de jouer pour tout le monde on
a vraiment un très bon accueil c'est
cette semaine très bien reçu
est-ce que tu
entends
d'applaudissements on a eu des gens un
petit peu surpris et agacés je le
reconnais on peut pas plaire à tout le
monde mais en tout cas on a eu d'impact
en 2011 pas moins de 2400 infractions
ont été commises sur ces deux lignes
entraînant 13000 minutes de retard sur
l'ensemble du réseau Transilien le coût
des fraudes et des incivilités est
évaluée à plus de 100 millions d'euros
la compagnie des rails a sévit une
dernière fois ce jeudi soir en gare de
trappe